moment the verdict in the kyle
rittenhouse double murder trial could
come at any moment inside the courtroom
right now a jury of seven women and five
men are deliberating the charges against
rittenhouse earlier today the 18 year
old randomly picking the group of people
who will decide his fate outside
protesters are gathering on the steps of
the courthouse and the national guard on
standby in the city of kenosha as local
officials call for calm when the verdict
comes down the key issue for the jurors
to decide was written house acting in
self-defense or did he intend to kill
two people and wound another prosecutors
say rittenhouse was a vigilante and
expecting violence while the defense
making the case that he was attacked
while trying to protect the community
everybody takes the beating sometimes
right
sometimes you get in a
scuffle and maybe you do get hurt a
little bit
that doesn't mean you get to start
plugging people with your full metal
jacket ar-15 what the defendant wants
you to believe is that because he's the
one who brought the gun
he gets to kill when the defendant
provokes the incident he loses the right
to self-defense kyle was a 17 year old
kid
out there trying to help this community
but the district attorney's office is
marching forward with this case because
they need somebody to be responsible
kyle rittenhouse's behavior
was protected under the law of the state
of wisconsin the law of self-defense and
the media coverage of this case facing a
new scrutiny for a rush to judgment
before the facts came out
they're having a protest in another
state and he takes it upon himself to go
there you know and then he says it's
self-defense no crying on the witness
stand like he's some poor babe in the
woods and he just happened to cross
state lines uh break gun laws on
cross-examination what we saw was i
thought a very rehearsed kyle ridden
house the black kid did that killed two
people and injured another person how
would america feel about that these are
the victims these are the people that
people ought to remember are the people
who were hurt here not the person who
was crying on the stand basically what
they're saying is oh it's okay to shoot
white people too
geraldo let's start with you um from a
legal perspective and uh somebody who's
followed this case closely and then
we'll take it on the table too well i
think the
verdict should if the jurists stick to
the law result in an acquittal i think
once they dropped the less serious
charges that made
the possibility of a clean sweep more
likely why because self-defense is so
powerful in wisconsin particularly and i
think that it's pretty clear that this
kid however uh you know i i personally
feel that he has been lionized way over
the top
that uh he has been portrayed by half
this country as a heroic uh
youngster fighting for his community i
don't believe that at all i think he
watched too many rambo movies uh uh he's
he's a is a kid that took an ar if it
took a machine gun to a uh to a riot i
think that it was not a machine gun
and he's too young to watch randy
then you don't have cable tv or direct
you think rambo but he's not on trial
for those things
my point is he will be acquitted he
should be acquitted but i think that
this is what is very distressing and i
made a point of uh telling my dear
colleague here we have to be careful not
to root for an outcome in a criminal
case let these jurors decide based on
the facts and circumstances as they were
presented the legal evidence that was
presented
i must say that well after
my appearance here last week i found the
uh the articles that had the pictures of
him giving the uh uh the white supremacy
uh uh uh sign
qt you i get the picture here you're wet
joking what you're you actually believe
this is a white supremacy sign what do
you think it is it's okay okay
holy cow including the president let it
be i i hope you're right i hope i hope
i'm wrong and let the you you ladies and
gentlemen in the audience know better
than i
because as i said i only came to this
last week but if indeed he is connected
with the white supremacists that gives
you an added layer of you're smearing
him again you're smearing him with a lie
roll though they checked his phone
what is this is that real
there was not one thing about militia or
white supremacy on the phone not one
okay
checked his phone nothing on it so
that's that it's just so that's that's
just the coincidence so that's the point
all right okay i'm saying
you say you're a lawyer you're based on
facts and you bring up something about
this and what is that means nothing to
you yes means nothing all right great
i hope it's not like i said it's a baby
maybe gut felt is right maybe jesse
maybe i'll show you barack obama going
like this okay emmanuel lewis was doing
this i brought that all right and who
was he standing with all right let me
get shady you know he's probably sitting
with farrakhan right now
he took a picture with farrakhan all
right you know he was
who was he was standing with
who was he standing with i don't know i
i i would read the article but jesse
we can go back we can go back to the
next pelosi
we can go back to the facts of the case
and what happened and the reason why
we're in the situation geraldo the
reason we're here is because a mob of
criminal adults and rioters including a
man who was shot and killed who was a
multi-time
pedophile child rapist attacked kyle
because he was in kenosha putting out
the fires at the buildings that the
rioters were starting the police were
not there to stop the rioters from
starting these fires or to put out the
fires kyle was there doing that and so
they didn't like that very much and
therefore they attacked him they
assaulted him and they threatened to
kill him which is why he ended up
defending himself in self-defense two
days before the riots this is also
something a lot of people don't know
another band of criminals showed up in
kenosha with rifles rioters who
confronted the police and the police
backed off and that's why the police
weren't there that day to stop the
rioters from fighting fires uh the men
in this case who have been killed joseph
rosenbaum
child rapist sent 15 years in prison
anthony huber had a felony strangulation
and suffocation
charge against him pulled a knife on his
brother and his grandmother engaged
gross royce who was the one who was shot
but uh survived
charged with armed with a gun while
being intoxicated also a crime admitted
in court that he stuck a gun in kyle's
face and that's why he was shot by kyle
in self-defense i wonder though on the
other side of this house think about
this last night how could you go through
the case and come to the conclusion that
you did that kyle should be acquitted
well
what if people are watching a week's
worth of video and the town burning down
and going i don't want that to happen
again so i have to come to a different
conclusion that's not what the jury
instructions are but there are threats
about this the jury was not sequestered
there are people outside the courtroom
and there are 500 national guard agent
or soldiers in town to prevent something
like this from happening so what if
they're seeing it from the other
perspective of if i don't make the right
decision based on the mob
then my family is going to be threatened
the protesters from the i'm sure
they said that in the courtroom you
could hear the protesters outside so
surely the jury were wherever they are
in that room or i could probably
it was the point i made after chauvin
when i go like oh i'm relieved he was
found guilty so my city won't burn and
people thought oh that's a terrible
thing to say i was making a comment on
society and that's how it is how now
society dictates how people decide in
court we're watching businesses getting
boarded up on what i call an mih a media
induced hurricane right we should have
categories for this the media induces
this by deliberately weighting the
coverage in a way that they want so both
cnn and msmbc chose not to show most if
not all of the closing arguments from
the defense so what you're left with is
what you heard from the prosecution
which is that one of them didn't have a
gun when he had a gun uh that or or that
uh rittenhouse is a racist or doesn't
like blacks he ignored he was he wasn't
doing the attacking he wasn't being
attacked so by only showing one side of
this that makes
the riots more justified when tubin says
the judge misled the jury on cnn that
means the justice was not served
therefore the activists can say okay
here we go again we have to go out there
and burn everything down so the media
just pushes the lie again and again that
no justice can be had this is the
difference between humanity and media
for humanity we live by the boy who
cried wolf it's a necessary fable to
build trust
when a boy who cries wolf cries wolf you
don't trust him that's a morality tale
in the media it's a profit model right
for the media the boy who cried wolf is
what they do with race what they do with
climate what they do with guns because
it's their goddamn profit model that's
why they keep doing it and they're doing
it again sorry i swore
that's all right i think that's what i
should say gosh darn permission to swear
was granted uh in
send retrospect letters to dana for
letting me do that i don't want you to
get in trouble i don't want you in
trouble um
let me wrap it up whatever you want
i mean i have a lot to say i think we
got to go to a commercial break they
said we have to all right well then here
we go
so this is what the left did they
falsely label something racist the blake
shooting and then that justifies their
riots because a riot against racism has
to be righteous right that justifies all
of their ransacking and looting and
burning and you can't get in the way of
a righteous riot right that makes you
racist right so
kyle got in the way and he should have
just taken a beating that's what the
prosecution said just take your beating
kyle didn't take the beating kyle used
self-defense and that's what they can't
have they had to make an example out of
kyle they have to chill other people for
trying to protect their own communities
also total snobs oh why would you want
to have to protect kenosha it's just
flyover country just a bunch of
middle-class roofs with you know maybe
some fires got started at a car
dealership whoopee
who cares well you know it's the other
thing if they come after santa barbara
georgetown or the hamptons that's
private property that's expensive that's
worth protecting so they're conditioning
the country to bow to the mob they're
conditioning the country to not use
their second amendment right and they're
using psychological warfare as greg said
they will basically take a huge villain
a pedophile a lying communist and turn
the guy into a hero or they'll take a
guardian of a community and make that
guy a villain he's the guardian of the
king and this is he went there to give
medical aid and put out fires all right
and that confuses the country and then
democrats exploit that confusion for
power all right more to come at 7 pm
prime time all right unless you get
bumped hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else